javelin
harley quinn he's obviously playing
margot robbie obviously
poke it up man wow okay so that's
obviously a big comical villain
rat catcher okay
idris elba is playing who is he playing
bloodsport no one guessed it king shaw
i'm interested to see you playing king
shark actually
cgi character obviously mainly
mongol okay peter capaldi
the thinker wow so obviously the thing
is quite a big dc villain
peter davison pete davison sorry black
guard
so it's quite a big they've got a
massive lineup here nathan phillian is
playing
sean gunn weasel okay so they've clearly
got a lot of characters that they can
just kill off jai courtney's obviously
back as captain boomerang
john cena is going to be the
peacemaker sorry my bad from charlton
comics
so that's a suicide squad lineup i'm
quite excited to see how this goes down
so in case you missed any of those
there's
obviously rick flag and that was sort of
the teaser
we are introducing the cast and the
characters are playing
of the suicide squad first of all we
have
idris elba as bloodsport nice
john cena as peacemaker
can't see him who is that as polka dot
man
nice obviously from the dog night as
well courtney as captain boomerang big
big
nathan fillion as tdk
lulaborg as javelin this is like a
really messed up big roster
and i like how it's kind of the the
d-less characters
so they can just kill them all off rat
catcher 2 is quite interesting
obviously with agenda
[Music]
[Applause]
michael rooker unfortunately is savant
i deal with the devil peter capaldi as
the thinker big i like the thing
crazy he looks a bit
juan diego boco is general presidente
sylvia luna
okay real great guy joel kinnaman
is of course with flag ella davis
is amanda waller and of course
margot robbie as harley
[Music]
excited this is gonna be great
you